[Musique]
oui
le design spot est né de la volonté de
l'université paris saclay de constituer
un centre de design qui est vu comme un
centre de ressources à disposition des
établissements qui sont présents sur le
plateau de saclay alors ces
établissements sont de plusieurs ordres
ça peut être des labos de recherche a
peut être les filières entrepreneurial
des écoles
ça peut même
aussi être des incubateurs ou des
accélérateurs et l'idée est de permettre
à ces établissements donc de profiter
d'une expérience design de façon à
enrichir en quelque sorte leur projet de
recherche de leurs projets de
développement avec un regard qui est un
petit peu différent de celui qui est
porté habituellement par les
scientifiques sur leurs projets donc
c'est une volonté d'élargissement c'est
une volonté aussi de d'essayer de faire
en sorte que le design amène un mode de
pensée différents en matière de
deux projets de recherche un mode de
pensée qui est principalement centrée
sur les utilisateurs qui sont parfois un
peu oubliée par les chercheurs
quand ils sont consacrés à développer
énormément d'énergie à la résolution
technique ou scientifique de leur sujet
pour nous notre but c'est d'essayer de
ne pas perdre de vue le consommateur et
quand on ne perd pas de vue le
consommateur on ne perd pas de vue non
plus les applications réelles commercial
virer éventuelle de c2c rechercher les
actions du centre de design du design
spots sont articulées autour de trois
axes principaux le premier c'est de
faire rentrer design dans les projets de
recherche quand je lui ai indiqué au
total europe et le deuxième axe c'est la
sensibilisation de façon à inciter les
chercheurs à avoir recours aux
disciplines du design et cette
sensibilisation elle consiste à
expliquer le mieux possible et plus
clairement possible
quelles sont les vertus du design les
plus values le de ces disciplines
un troisième axe existe également pour
le design spot c'est la recherche de
façon à faire progresser cette
discipline pour recherche qui peut être
établi sur le design elle même ou par le
design mais toujours avec la volonté de
faire en sorte que cette discipline soit
de plus en plus efficaces j'ai pour ma
part la conviction que réunir science &
design c'est réunir le meilleur de la
société de demain c'est à dire à la fois
une approche scientifique mais aussi une
approche qui est centré sur l'humain
plus émotionnelle
plus empathique mais néanmoins toujours
connectée également au marché
[Musique]